A menudo se dice que se puede saber mucho sobre una persona
al ver lo que está en sus libreros.
¿Qué dicen mis libreros de mí?
Bueno, cuando me hice esta pregunta hace unos años,
hice un descubrimiento alarmante.
Siempre me había visto como alguien bastante culta
y cosmopolita.
Pero mis librerías contaban una historia bastante diferente.
Prácticamente todos los títulos
eran de autores británicos o norteamericanos,
y no había casi nada traducido.
El descubrimiento de este masivo punto ciego cultural en mis lecturas
me dejó en shock.
Y cuando pensé en ello, me pareció una verdadera lástima.
Sabía que tenía que haber muchas historias increíbles por ahí
de escritores que escriben en lenguas diferentes al inglés.
Y parecía muy triste pensar que por mis hábitos de lectura
probablemente nunca me toparía con ellos.
Así que decidí automedicarme
un curso intensivo de lectura global.
El 2012 se pensó para ser
un año muy internacional para el Reino Unido;
fue el año de los Juegos Olímpicos de Londres.
Así que decidí utilizarlo como mi calendario
para tratar de leer una novela, una colección de cuentos
o una memoria de todos los países del mundo.
Y así lo hice.
Y fue muy emocionante
y aprendí algunas cosas notables
e hice algunas conexiones maravillosas
que quiero compartirles hoy.
Pero comenzó con algunos problemas prácticos.
Después de haber decidido
cuál de las diversas listas de países en el mundo
usar para mi proyecto,
terminé siguiendo la lista de naciones reconocidas por la ONU,
a la que añadí Taiwán,
que me dio un total de 196 países.
Y después de haber resuelto cómo ajustar la lectura y bloggeo
de aproximadamente, cuatro libros a la semana
trabajando cerca de cinco días a la semana,
entonces tuve que enfrentar el hecho de que incluso no podría ser capaz
de conseguir libros en inglés de todos los países.
Solo alrededor de un 4.5% de las obras literarias publicadas
cada año en el Reino Unido son traducciones
y las cifras son similares para gran parte del mundo de habla inglesa.
Sin embargo, la proporción de publicaciones de libros traducidos
en muchos otros países es mucho más alta.
4.5% es lo suficientemente pequeño para empezar,
pero lo que esa cifra no dice
es que muchos de esos libros vendrán de países
con fuertes redes editoriales
y muchos profesionales de la industria
preparados para salir a vender esos títulos
a las editoriales en idioma inglés.
Así, por ejemplo, aunque poco más de 100 libros
se traducen del francés
y se publican cada año en el Reino Unido
la mayoría de ellos vendrán de países como Francia o Suiza.
Por otro lado, la África de habla francesa,
rara vez se tendrá en cuenta.
El resultado es que hay muchas naciones
que pueden tener poca o ninguna literatura comercial en inglés disponible.
Sus libros siguen siendo invisibles
para los lectores del lenguaje con más publicaciones del mundo.
Pero cuando se trataba de leer el mundo,
el mayor reto de todos para mí
fue el hecho de no saber por dónde empezar.
Después de haber pasado la vida leyendo casi exclusivamente libros británicos
y de norteamérica
no tenía idea de cómo conseguir y encontrar historias
y escogerlas entre muchas del resto del mundo.
No podría decidir cómo conseguir una historia de Swazilandia.
No conocía una buena novela de Namibia.
No podía ocultarlo:
Era una xenófoba literaria sin idea.
Entonces, ¿cómo era posible que yo fuera a leer el mundo?
Iba a tener que pedir ayuda.
Así, en octubre de 2011, registré mi blog,
ayearofreadingtheworld.com,
y publiqué una corta petición en línea.
Expliqué quién era,
lo cerrada que había sido mi lectura,
y pedí a quien quisiera
que dejara un mensaje sugiriendo qué podría leer
de otras partes del planeta.
Ahora bien, no tenía ni idea si alguien estaría interesado,
pero luego de unas cuantas horas de publicar mi petición en línea,
la gente empezó a ponerse en contacto.
Al principio, eran amigos y colegas.
Luego eran amigos de mis amigos.
Y muy pronto, fueron extraños.
Cuatro días después de poner mi petición en línea,
recibí un mensaje de una mujer llamada Rafidah en Kuala Lumpur.
Me dijo que le encantaba cómo sonaba mi proyecto
y que podría ir a su librería local de libros en inglés
y escoger mi libro de Malasia y enviármelo.
Acepté con entusiasmo,
y unas semanas más tarde,
llegó un paquete con no uno, sino dos libros,
la elección de Rafidah de Malasia,
y un libro de Singapur que también había elegido para mí.
En ese momento, me sorprendió
que un extraño a casi 10 mil km. de distancia
fuera tan lejos para ayudar a alguien
que probablemente nunca conocería.
Pero la bondad de Rafidah resultó ser el patrón en ese año.
Una y otra vez, la gente hacía lo posible para ayudarme.
Algunos se dieron a la investigación en mi nombre
y otros hicieron desvíos en vacaciones y viajes de negocios
para ir a las librerías por mí.
Resulta que, si quieres leer el mundo,
si quieres encontrarlo con mente abierta,
el mundo te ayudará.
Cuando se trataba de países
con poca o ninguna literatura comercial en inglés disponible
las personas fueron aún más lejos.
A menudo los libros provenían de fuentes sorprendentes.
Mi lectura de Panamá, por ejemplo, vino a través de una conversación
que tuve en Twitter con el Canal de Panamá
Sí, el Canal de Panamá tiene una cuenta de Twitter.
Y cuando le envié un Tweet sobre mi proyecto,
sugirió qué podría probar conseguir el trabajo
del autor panameño Juan David Morgan.
Encontré el sitio web de Morgan y le envié un mensaje,
preguntando si alguna de sus Novelas en español
se habían traducido al inglés.
Me respondió que no había nada publicado,
pero tenía una traducción inédita
de su novela "El Caballo de Oro".
Me la envió por correo electrónico
lo que me permitió ser una de las primeras personas
en leer ese libro en inglés.
Morgan no fue de ninguna manera el único escritor
en compartir su trabajo conmigo de esta forma.
De Suecia a Palau,
escritores y traductores me enviaron libros publicados individualmente
y manuscritos inéditos de libros
que rechazaban las editoriales de habla inglesa
o que ya no estaban disponibles,
dándome atisbos privilegiados de algunos mundos imaginarios notables.
Leí, por ejemplo,
sobre el rey de África Austral Ngungunhane, que lideró la resistencia
contra los portugueses en el siglo XIX;
y sobre los rituales matrimoniales en una aldea remota
a orillas del Mar Caspio en Turkmenistán.
Conocí la respuesta de Kuwait para Bridget Jones.
(Risas)
Y leí sobre una orgía en un árbol en Angola.
Pero tal vez el ejemplo más sorprendente
de las molestias que las personas estaban dispuestas a tomar
para ayudarme a leer el mundo,
llegó hacia el final de mi búsqueda,
cuando buscaba un libro de la pequeña nación insular africana
de habla portuguesa Santo Tomé y Príncipe.
Después de haber pasado varios meses
intentando todo lo que pude para encontrar
un libro traducido al inglés de esta nación,
parecía que la única opción que me quedaba
era ver si podía conseguir algo traducido para mí desde cero.
Realmente dudaba
si alguien iba a querer ayudar con esto,
y renunciar a su tiempo para algo así.
Pero, tras una semana de hacer un llamado en Twitter y Facebook
para hablantes de portugués,
tenía más gente de la que podía involucrar en el proyecto,
incluyendo a Margaret Jull Costa, una líder en su campo,
que ha traducido la obra del Premio Nobel José Saramago.
Con mis nueve voluntarios listos,
me las arreglé para encontrar un libro de un autor de Santo Tomé
del que podía comprar suficientes copias en línea.
Aquí está uno.
Envié una copia a a cada una de mis voluntarios.
Todos tomaron un par de historias cortas de esta colección,
trabajaron, me enviaron sus traducciones,
y al cabo de seis semanas, tenía todo el libro para leer.
En ese caso, y como me ocurrió tan a menudo durante ese año,
mi falta de conocimiento y el estar abierta acerca de mis limitaciones
se habían convertido en una gran oportunidad.
En el caso de Santo Tomé y Príncipe,
fue una oportunidad no solo para aprender algo nuevo
y descubrir una nueva colección de historias,
sino también para reunir un grupo de personas
y facilitar un esfuerzo creativo conjunto.
Mi debilidad se había convertido en la fortaleza del proyecto.
Los libros que leí ese año me abrieron los ojos a muchas cosas.
Como quienes disfrutan de la lectura sabrán,
los libros tienen el poder extraordinario de llevarte fuera de ti mismo
y ponerte en la mente de alguien más,
de modo que, durante un tiempo al menos,
miras el mundo a través de los ojos de alguien más.
Esa puede ser una experiencia incómoda,
especialmente si estás leyendo un libro
de una cultura que puede tener valores bastante diferentes a los tuyos.
Pero también puede ser muy esclarecedor.
Luchar con ideas poco familiares ayuda a clarificar tu propio pensamiento.
Y también puede mostrarte puntos ciegos
en la forma en que podrías haber estado mirando al mundo.
Cuando volví a la literatura en inglés
con la que había crecido, por ejemplo,
empecé a ver lo estrecha que era mucha de ella,
en comparación con la riqueza que el mundo tiene para ofrecer.
Y a medida que pasaba las páginas,
también comenzó a suceder algo.
Poco a poco,
esa larga lista de país con la que había empezado el año,
pasó de un registro de nombres de lugares más bien seco y académico
a uno de entidades vivas que respiran.
No quiero sugerir que es en forma alguna posible
obtener una imagen redondeada de un país
simplemente leyendo un libro.
Pero acumulativamente, las historias que leí ese año
me hicieron más conciente que nunca
de la riqueza, diversidad y complejidad de nuestro notable planeta.
Era como si las historias del mundo
y las personas que habían llegado a tales extremos para ayudarme a leerlos
lo hubieran hecho real para mí.
Hoy en día, cuando veo mis estanterías
o miro las obras en mi e-reader,
me cuentan una historia muy diferente.
Es la historia del poder que tienen los libros para conectarnos a través
de divisiones políticas, geográficas, religiosas, sociales, culturales.
Es sobre el potencial en el que tienen que trabajar juntos los seres humanos.
Su testamento
a los tiempos extraordinarios en que vivimos
en donde, gracias a la Internet,
es más fácil que nunca para un extraño
compartir una historia, una visión del mundo, un libro
con alguien que tal vez nunca conocerá, al otro lado del planeta.
Espero que sea una historia que leeré durante muchos años por venir
y espero que mucha más gente me siga.
Si todos leemos más ampliamente, los editores tendrían más incentivos
para traducir más libros,
y todos nos enriqueceríamos por eso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)